i think you should protect kids
innocence honestly like because once
well what's not innocent about about
being transgender
no i'm i'm looking at it oh you're
talking about truth because because
transgenderism is like it's an anomaly
right and it's like
children that much of an anomaly if we
have to talk about it is my point though
yeah but children all right so but
children shouldn't be taught about in my
personal point of view should we talk
about shouldn't it be taught about sex
at a young age anyway especially not a
sexual orientation that in my personal
point of view is about um
confusion more so than sexual
orientation so it's like are you trying
to show children that
this sexual orientation is quote unquote
normal
where if we look at it it isn't
it's first of all it's an anomaly
second of all they talk about it's it
can be a but why not it can be
it can be looked at as a as a
psychological or physiological because
they say gender dysphoria
explaining to a nine-year-old child what
gender dysphoria is they don't know what
gender is for yourself so it you could
keep it simplistic is my point you have
to keep it kid-friendly but the thing is
transgenderism isn't simplistic
you're making it seem like it's far more
complicated than it is you can just say
here is someone who was born a boy they
don't feel comfortable being a boy they
don't feel like they're right in their
body and in their mind they feel more
comfortable with playing with the girls
yeah they he they like playing with the
dolls and the makeup and whatever it may
be that
what i know
that's
exposing them that's exposing them to
like mental issues at such a young age
yeah so you think being trans is a
mental issue
of course it is it's not a phys it's not
a biological uh you don't have to say of
course you take it down a notch no but
no but it's true it's not it's not a
biological one
it's a mental one right
if you think you're something that
you're actually not that's in your head
just like you think you're a 10 out of
10 what
i never said you think you're 11 out of
10 which is in your head so what i'm
trying to say is if you're if you're
talking about
something that isn't if we can look in
your body and we can see you have two
testicles on the penis
we know what you are right if you think
you are other than what you actually are
that's something going on in your head
right because couldn't i identify as a
teenager
if i wanted to trans age they call it
no i'm serious no i've gone into this
what if i said i feel i feel 17. yeah i
am 17. well that would genuinely be
something that you would have to work
with and being someone who studies psych
yeah that would more than likely be a
trauma response
because transgender is so much i was not
done speaking people who struggle
with their age at least right
um who still feel like they're stuck in
their teen years or even childhood years
usually experience some sort of terrible
trauma at that age in their life and
that's where they feel emotionally and
physically stunted yeah so that's why
like maybe later on they still act a
certain way for years but it's
interesting because you're kind of
saying like that's a that's like a
mental disorder yeah no i can i can say
that with peace yeah
but but trans wouldn't be so trans women
i can't see it that way because i'm
someone who's part of the lgbt community
yeah and i see how these people struggle
and
like you know like people tend to make
the argument that that's an emotional
response it's not a logical one
do you want to answer or not yeah but
it's not quite an emotional response yes
it's a yes or no question
it's a yes or no question a logical one
it's a yes or no question
talk about the facts not the feelings
please
i think guys get along
let's talk about the facts of the
feelings it's like
regardless these things were removed
from the dsm-5 yeah uh being transgender
gender dysphoria is still in there i
believe and they're working on the dsm-6
i believe if not it's already out but um
it's difficult to pinpoint that as a
mental illness
only because this is a whole
this is something that someone's willing
to change their entire life for i can't
change my entire life to be 17.
i mean [ __ ] you could try you could try
hang on rachel dolezal changed her
entire life to be black oh my gosh do
you know who that is yeah right she was
head of the naacp
and she was a white woman yeah so just
because she identifies or thought of
herself as black doesn't mean that she
is but that doesn't make these people
any less human i think that's what i'm
trying to do we're not no but we're not
talking as i'm saying you're talking
from an emotional standpoint i never
said trans people or whoever you are are
less human they are human beings they
deserve their rights as a human human
being
but it doesn't mean that's what they're
saying even respect their identity is
the issue
so if a trans person would you mean
respect their identity if somebody were
to come to you right now they were trans
they once were she
and became he
and you knew this would you refer to
them as
what they are comfortable with or what
they were originally born as i would
refer to them as who they are which is a
man or a woman biologically because what
you're asking me to do essentially so
then that's just disrespectful no it's
not just in disregard
i'll tell you what's disrespectful
what's disrespectful for me is to ask me
to buy into your delusion
that's what i think is disrespectful if
i come up to you and say listen i know
i'm a black man but please call me uh
mei ling because i'm now a chinese woman
you're gonna be like
all right you're a chinese you're good
i'm a chinese woman really and you've
met me and you know me prior to me
identifying as a chinese woman you're
now gonna call me meling i'm now asking
you
to id to buy into my delusion if i feel
like this that's
100 cool but i shouldn't ask you
to buy into what i think of myself
because like i said you think of
yourself as a 11 out of 10
right if you went around asking people
to call you an 11 out of 10 and that's
just plain arrogant and egotistical
because you're awesome i wouldn't do
that though right but
yeah but trans people all i ask is basic
respect basically people do they ask
people to call them the thing that they
know that they actually aren't
the way they see themselves genuinely
not that hard to just refer to them as
she her or he him as they ask and by the
name that they choose to go by it's
genuinely not that hard my name is
francesca right but i go by chesca that
is my preferred name all i have to do is
tell you hey this is what i prefer to be
called feel free to call me this right
and it would be up to you to call me
chesca i would like i said i would
prefer it if you call me francesca i'm
not going to respond because
realistically i i don't like that name
as much as cheska
it's that stuff
it's a it's a respect thing it's no it's
not shooting in your name yeah is not
the same as asking me to call you by a
totally different gender okay so there's
no part of you that is that gender maybe
if they preferred a different name even
you wouldn't go with that
if they preferred it
like i said you're asked i'm not about
they went with a different name
if they ask me to call them a name if i
came to you and i said i prefer the name
richard even though i clearly am not
biologically male i'll be like what what
are your parents questions okay what are
your parents you're not my parents so
you wouldn't have a right to call me
whatever it is you wouldn't have the
right i asked me to call you wouldn't
have the right to call me by whatever my
parents call me because my parents are
different from you you're just a 40 year
old man okay you're just a stranger that
i see on the top you don't touch me now
you're just a stranger that i see on a
podcast so tesco like okay